so kommt die tombola
wir haben wieder wirklich uns ordentlich
die köpfe zermatt hat wie wir dich
ärgern können und wie wir nett zu dir
sein können die roten sind gemeint die
roten sind ja jetzt nur grüne genau
umgekehrt sein album ist wie aus einem
guss was ist dein geheimrezept ich weiß
gar nicht was mein geheimrezept ist es
gibt zum glück nichts dieses rezept
jemanden album macht und ich weiß auch
gar nicht genau was aus einem guss ist
also wenn du damit meinst aus einem guss
dann vielleicht dass man es durch hören
kann dann ist das natürlich ein super
schönes kompliment weil das ist mir
persönlich ganz wichtig aber aus einem
guss jeder song ist er anders jeder hat
eine andere entstehung und was ich
vorhin auch schon gesagt habe ich denke
gar nicht so viel darüber nach musik
machen es immer intuitiv ich mache musik
und bin immer wieder auch überrascht
wohin und ja wie die songs dann bei den
leuten noch ankommen so und was leute
irgendwie mit der musik verbinden und
wie die musik aufnehmen
es gibt auch ganz viele stimmen die
sagen das ist überhaupt nicht aus einem
guss das sind irgendwie ganz
verschiedene musikstile die da wild
durcheinander geworfen sind zum
kritikpunkt deswegen bin ich schon
jemand der lob aber auch kritik
irgendwie sich zwar an hat aber dann
doch nicht zu sehr in mich aufnehmen
das lenkt dann doch eher das ist ein
punkt wo man dann zu tief einsteigt und
man sich ja auch das gut dann wo man da
nicht zu sehr investieren kann auch
etwas gewinnen jetzt leider nicht aber
das wird das wird noch eine idee oder
sie mir so der sunniten wo dann gar
nichts drauf steht
diese frage ist eine niete das ist sie
in jedem fall jetzt
warum kommt fixum eigentlich immer noch
mit der ersten frage wie ist die lage
nein das steht da nicht du kennst die
fragen nicht immer aber in dem fall habe
ich zusammen daran höher läge was liegt
da will noch jemand reggae hören
ich glaube schon klar aber es gab schon
hochzeit gibt es oder ist gibt es die
hoch-zeit des reggae nie vorbei gegangen
also ich glaube nicht dass es so diese
hochzeit gab es gab vielleicht mal so
ein moment um ich glaube das war so
mitte der neunziger ja also wir reden
jetzt von unserem brasil die fragen
kannst du jetzt nicht in amerika stehen
dafür die lage dass er immer drauf an wo
es auch in afrika oder auch er ali
forney so unglaublich weit verbreitet
hier in deutschland wie wollen die leute
glaube ich eher weniger regen sonst
würde ich ins radio anmachen auch mal
andere künstler die mitmachen außerdem
ist man ja immer sagen stimmt ja sondern
auch künstler aus jamaika und das ist
nicht der fall
aber es gibt eine ganz gesunde subkultur
hier in deutschland es gibt viele
festivals die ganz ganz viele menschen
anziehen
und anscheinend ist ein interesse da für
mich ist die musik immer auch eine
politische musik sie übers entertainment
hinausgeht und die vielleicht auch nicht
unbedingt immer leicht verdaulich ist
und das ist vielleicht der grund warum
ist kein massen ring ist okay jetzt noch
die roten fahren ich finde die
interessanter
das stimmt die werden noch sehr
interessant
die spieler gerne fifa aber liebsten der
eigenen hälfte
willst du nicht mehr tore schießen ich
habe immer auch pampers dabei für mein
gegner aber der gegner mitspielen auch
immer auf tour für pampers viel tiefer
und dann gibt es natürlich verbal immer
großen schlagabtausch bevor das spiel
losgeht so und philipp unser sound man
hat wirklich das letzte mal dass meine
pemper sind meine kohle gelegt
ganz viele zewa wisch und weg ziehe ich
auch ja dann nachher holzländer des
spiels so okay ich bin grundsätzlich nie
in meiner hälfte ok ich gewinne immer
zweistellig ok der gott des fifa ich bin
der fifa grund sehr schön
also leute seid gewarnt
diese rote frage ist in dieser das ist
ja das geheimnis der oder fragen sie
überhaupt nehmen das gegenteil von ihm
bis jetzt
ich habe die frage zerrissen wann hast
du deinen letzten joint geraucht
dann habe ich meinen letzten also als
wir letztes mal das interview hatten
lehmann war das von zwei jahren zwei
jahren da hab ich gesagt irgendwie so
ich kiffe nicht mehr und habe dann
wieder angefangen
ok und hab dann auch wieder exzessiv
geraucht und jetzt traurig seid ich
glaube halben jahr oder so nicht also
ich glaube ich mache mal so phasen ja
aber also für mich ist viel einfacher zu
sagen ich rauche überhaupt nicht gar
nicht als ab und zu mal ich weiß nicht
wann ich den letzten jahren geordnet ist
irgendwie naja so acht monate ist es her
diese wenn du musik machst er mit oder
ohne das besser er ohne im moment also
ich mache halt ohne musik bin auch viel
auf der bühne und hab auch songs gemacht
und gesagt ich brauche es als
inspiration aber das ist auch irgendwie
nur eine einbildung sondern das
funktioniert auch
also brauch ist auch immer irgendwie
gegenteil von klarheit
das stimmt viele oder ich viele denken
unter drogeneinfluss wehrmann kreativer
wenn man wehrmann wehrmann aber
eigentlich ist nur die illusion dessen
kann sein weil das ist mein also ich
kann sehr gut auch ohne kiffen musik
machen aber auch habe auch gute mucke
mit gemacht also könnte okay seit 20
jahren erfolgreicher reggae-musiker
wieso hast du dich so lange gehalten
ja also ich finde es selbst manchmal
echt surreal dass das so vor augen
halten dass er seit 20 jahren schon so
geht das erste konzert war in köln und
293 im basement wir haben jetzt unser
jubiläum das war schon hat da schon eine
platte raus in basica 7 90 89 890 das
als fünf jahre später haben vielleicht
schon vorher spielt ich bin einfach nur
extrem dankbar dass er schon so lange
unglaublich auch wenn man zur fotos
angucken wie wertvoll die bubis und
irgendwie gerade aus der pubertät raus
warum das so ist weiß ich nicht glaube
das ist eben diese kombination aus ding
was ich vorhin auch gesagt habe die
richtigen leute die leidenschaft zur
musik wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
talent und auch dieses ding im moment zu
bleiben und nicht zu weit nach vorne zu
gucken
soweit es musik machen es so was
momentan ist es passiert jetzt hier und
finde ich habe mir nie so vorgestellt wo
bin ich denn fünf jahren und ich wollte
auch nie solcher toni dem plan bei
reggae sänger zu binden dass ich morgens
aufgewacht bin hatte ich will mal noch
mal was hast du denn gedacht also dass
jamaika damals geflogen ist hat sich da
war oder man also dahin geflogen ist was
wolltest du da ich weiß ich nicht auch
ja aber das war jetzt nicht der primäre
grund sondern ich mich hat das land
fasziniert auch bevor ich da war schon
von erzählungen von der musik die aus
dieser kleinen insel kommt was davon
unglaublich kreativer input ist also
seine kombination aus ding einfach mal
was zu erleben heraus zu kommen aber ich
bin also mein gefühl gefolgt das war
weniger im kopf sondern mehr sind auch
ich musste es wird wasser oder was nicht
war nicht da soll ich dann wird es mal
zeit also wenn ich finde ich gut da kann
es auch irgendwie viele interessante
menschen treffen
was haben wir denn noch wie wird man
eigentlich als deutscher musiker
international erfolgreich indem man auf
ich weiß nicht früher hat sich bei four
music sound war erste platte 1998 zwei
dinge die kann man raus und ganz viele
leute an sagt er man so cool was du
machst aber sind noch auf deutsch ja das
ist doch irgendwie gibt ja viele die auf
deutschland muss ich auch gut anhört und
wo es auch in sohland floss aber für
mich war das irgendwie ich hab's einfach
nicht gefühlt warum keine ahnung
das war für mich das ding so zu sagen
ich mache es auf englisch und das ist
der grund warum oder einer der gründe
glaube ich warum international auch
funktioniert wenn ich auf deutsch singen
würde dann wäre es glaube ich schwierig
in amerika und in china und in
südamerika sondern wer es eher reduziert
auf deutschland schweiz österreich und
die musiker in musik also ricky ist
international einfach sehr weit
verbreitet weil es gibt ja viele auch
deutsche günter die auf englisch singen
die aber trotzdem nur in deutschland
erfolgreich sind oder flächen russ dann
wenn ich jetzt einmal
aber eigentlich kommt in fast nie über
deutsche grenzen hinaus aber ich stelle
mir so fragen gar nicht so oft darum was
erfolgreich ist gut vielen dank dank
auch mal wieder spannend
das gut alles gut